give you a true story places instant
incident happened to me last year I was
flying before the coven of course I was
flying and I thought we were waiting
there is a man who was looking at me and
looking at me and looking at me I mean
me I said I'm sure he Allah knows he's
probably like what is this woman
whatever
and then like I hate the law that man
comes and sits next to me in the plane
and it's 1 hour and a half and one and a
half hour is all this discussion he
turned to be a priest she was a priest
yes so you're here this is a priest
sitting next to you on the plane and he
was he look how it started and he and he
was after this night you're living in
this or living in that and he said you
probably noticed I was looking at you in
the waiting room in the waiting area and
I said yes I did and he said I asked
myself is she a Christian Catholic or
she may be and here then he said no no
no I said I think she's almost him and
all the discussion is told he
immediately know what he said he said
what you are wearing reminded me of Mary
so he didn't have to say anything so
that you didn't even have seen it that
the Christian priest he looks at you and
said what you're wearing is reminding me
of obviously Jesus's mother Mary exactly
yeah the Christian priests told you this
way Jeff and then we went and the whole
discussion was actually about women
rights in Islam it's amazing amazing
absolutely people ask you right and and
sisters ask me Muslims ask him why do
you do it my first answer and I want
everyone listen to me listening to me
learn this and may Allah Ta'ala put it
in your heart as he put it in mine and I
say anything why you're wearing your
head cover or while you are wearing your
stomach attire I say because Allah asked
me to do it period and then they say is
it a choice this is the second question
you always get and I said it's your
choice in mind to obey Allah or not your
day
and I need to get the
the day of judgment when I'm standing in
front of him and I better prepare a very
good answer why I chose not only you
know what I'm saying we really have to
look at it's a Islam and and I think one
of the issues you you tackled it in the
beginning I think it's also the way we
were taught or it is being taught Islam
is a personal relationship between you
and your Creator and it's a relationship
of love oh and there is fear and not
fear from him so Hannah no it's fear of
of lack of is pleasure and long if you
look at your religion this way so what
you cover your hair so what if you don't
get this job because they didn't give it
to you you know what I'm saying yeah
everything becomes very trivial so yes
I've absolutely had this not recently
and I actually love it because this is
my opportunity mm-hmm I was like I love
it yeah it just came to my mind sorry
last question but yeah what do you what
do you say because sometimes the the the
head covering has been limited just to
the top part and then you'll see some
unfortunately someone might have some
good intention but it goes back to what
you're saying the proper knowledge so
you have some sisters so wear this but
everything else is like a skirt or what
now how do you address that I guess I
get this question all the time right is
makeup haram nail polish
can I wear jeans right all these
questions everybody asked it it's not
only men it's men and women and muslims'
and non-muslim elevate questions for our
times yeah it's important yeah and it is
very important and my answer is you know
what I always try to avoid the word
phenomenal unless it's very clear
especially if you're talking to a person
who's not yet grounded I say always look
at the essence of it what is the word
hijab right and look at it in surah Noor
in chapter 2 the light in the Quran
Allah how Allah said he didn't say the
word hijab here in that context he
actually says don't show your beauty
right don't show your beauty so
I tell the woman when they tell me what
should I dress but what do I wear I said
if you are putting anything on your body
that is showing the beauty of your body
you're not doing what a lot one's done
while you're putting makeup to look more
beautiful X outside it's not pleasing to
Allah is that what he said he says like
Gina's in a dominant don't show your
beauty nail polish same thing so when I
and I this I say this to all my
beautiful sisters I said if I see you
and I know what size dress you are
wearing then you need to look at maybe
you are not following exactly what a lot
once I achieve when I have when I also
it does not describe the body you cannot
say you cannot see through and can I be
and this is to the sisters can I be
elegant can I be modern can I be looking
beautiful in the way pleasing to Allah
the answer is absolutely yes
alhamdulillah especially these things
but again is the influences and the
priorities may Allah teach us all may
Allah make things easy for everybody for
the men to practice for the woman to
practice for the children to practice
may Allah Allah Muhammad a man a man was
a you know vehicle in viña you know this
duaa yah Allah make us love a man make
us love faith and we used to fight in
our hearts Allah said this was Altered
Hadid it's because once I love something
I do it and you know when I see someone
disobeying Allah you know what's my due
out to that person she or he you know
Allah take the love of this disobedient
outside their heart because if you don't
love it you don't do it yes hamdullah
may Allah reward you thank you so much
this is why we're sharing this
information and and talking to someone
like you is because we want the best for
all of mankind especially our brothers
and sisters out there thank you so much
for spending some time with us and
sharing all this important advice just
it's a pleasure I loved it may Allah
reward you
means our clients
[Music]